[Music]
it's happening after 133 years of
waiting the Vsauce soundtrack four long
playing vinyl records containing every
single Jake chudo song you have ever
heard on Vsauce and a best of record
containing 11 classic tracks both are
limited runs with pre-orders that close
on December 22nd Jake Cho's music is the
sound of curiosity it raises questions
but it also raised you his music has
been the Sonic texture of Vsauce for
more than a decade and finally it is all
being released pre-order now for
delivery later next year Jake and I are
still working on the artwork and telling
the stories behind each song most of
these songs have never been released and
have never been heard in their entirety
without me talking over them but now
they're liberated and it's you that they
[Music]
want